good evening the man and woman arrested
for killing a 70 year old man right in
front of his home got into an argument
with him at a bar just
before that shooting thanks for joining
us here at six i'm denise valdez
and i'm kirsten joyce that's all
according to an arrest report obtained
by 8 news now
for 36 year old otis buchanan and 31
year old delena smedley
the shooting happened sunday evening on
bennett drive that's near mountain vista
and tropicana
today was the first court appearance for
the pair smedley was not at the hearing
the judge says she was being disruptive
now according to police both of them
exchanged
words with the victim here allen
bondulid then followed him home and
apparently killed him
one question by detectives both denied
even being there
the couple was denied bail and are due
back in court on thursday
well tonight the family of that victim
is trying to process
his sudden death 8 news now reporter
christian drummond sat down with his son
to talk about his legacy which includes
a love of all things
tiki he was always constantly decorating
a pirate's paradise in the backyard
if he were here he'd be running around
turning all these things on
the sanctuary for alan bondalet a 70
year old man known by his son
ethan for his charisma and anything tiki
related
very social larger in life character he
thought every day was
kind of a party that party ending
suddenly on sunday when allen was
murdered in his driveway
it was nothing expected i'm glad we got
the holidays
together the arrest report states
surveillance video shows a man and woman
appear to have a verbal altercation with
allen at a bar
on boulder highway the argument
continued in the parking lot
then the duo followed him home police
say otis buchanan approached allen in
the driveway
demanding his wallet three times before
shooting him in the chest he just
crossed the wrong path i guess at the
wrong time this is unfortunate
we're going to miss him but allen's
legacy lives on in the backyard
he spent a lot of time back here just
every day cleaning the pool and making
sure the jacuzzi was ready for people to
come over
and and was constantly inviting people
back here small reminders of his passion
and
last 11 years living in las vegas it was
very social and every day when i was
waited just make people
feel good and be happy the family plans
to celebrate
allen's life and arrangements are being
made reporting in the southeast valley
kristin drummond 8 news now
allen and his wife were married for 48
years the family has set up a gofundme
account to help cover
funeral costs and other life adjust